This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The walk begins at the parking lot at the end of the road. The site isn't much to speak of, just a sprawling expanse of asphalt peppered with cars. Over a million people come here every year to embark on a kind of pilgrimage. They're here to cross the border. We are getting ready to go to Mexico this morning. Yes, one more time. so we shall see what the rest of the day hold.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。散步从路尽头的停车场开始。这个地方没什么好说的，不过是一片星罗棋布停满汽车的宽敞沥青路面。每年有上百万人来到这里，踏上一场某种意义上的朝圣之旅。他们来这里是为了过境。今天早上我们正准备去墨西哥。是的，再来一次。所以我们要看看今天剩下的时间会发生什么。
There are hundreds of videos online documenting this experience. Watch as many as I did, and they all start to meld together. That's 99PI producer, Lashemadon. Some people seem nervous in the videos. Others are more excited. Many will turn to their imagined audience behind the camera and speak in a reassuring tone. You see that American flag up there, y'all? This is one of the safest crossings. There is.
网上有数百段记录这段经历的视频。看过的视频和我一样多的话，它们就会开始融为一体。那是 99PI 的制作人拉舍·马登。视频中的有些人看起来很紧张。其他人则更兴奋。许多人会转向镜头后面想象中的观众，用令人安心的语气说话。各位，你们看到上面那面美国国旗了吗？这是最安全的过境点之一。这里就是。
And it's not scary, I promise you. It is not scary. Everyone here is headed to the same town in Mexico. It's called Los Algodonis, and it's a place where, for decades, Americans have roamed the streets. They come here in desperate search of something they need, something that's almost impossible to find where they live. They're looking for a dentist, one that they can afford. Every day, thousands of people, mostly American, mostly white, and mostly retired, come to this town looking for relief from the turmoil in their mouths. Here, dental care costs up to 80% less than what it might cost in the U.S. Dental tourism to Los Agadones is so common that many call this place Molar City.
而且并不可怕，我向这里保证。一点也不可怕。这里的每个人都前往墨西哥的同一个小镇。它叫洛斯阿尔戈多尼斯，几十年来，美国人一直在那里的街道上游荡。他们来到这里，绝望地寻找他们需要的东西，寻找一件在他们居住的地方几乎不可能找到的东西。他们在寻找牙医，一个他们负担得起的牙医。每天，成千上万的人，主要是美国人，主要是白人，也主要是退休人员，来到这个小镇，希望摆脱他们口中的痛苦。在这里，牙科护理的费用比在美国可能花费的费用低高达 80%。前往洛斯阿尔戈多尼斯的牙科旅游非常普遍，以至于许多人把这个地方叫做“磨牙城”。
Today, there are nearly a thousand dentists in this 7,000-person town, and 98% of those in the patient's chair traveled here from outside Mexico. Lasha is going to take it from here. Watch any one of these YouTube videos, and you'll see how a trip to Molar City is made easy for an American. For decades, this crossing didn't even require a passport. In one video, a retired couple arrives at Arizona's edge. They do a 360, displaying the massive lot where they've just parked.
如今，在这个拥有 7000 人的小镇里，有将近一千名牙医，而坐在病人椅上的人中有 98% 是从墨西哥以外的地方旅行到这里的。接下来由拉沙接手。看任何一个这样的 YouTube 视频，你就会明白去磨牙城对美国人来说是多么容易。几十年来，这个过境点甚至不需要护照。在一段视频中，一对退休夫妇抵达了亚利桑那州的边缘。他们做了一个 360 度转体，展示了他们刚刚停放车辆的巨大停车场。
We love Mexico, they say emphatically, talking to the camera. The camera then pans to show the rust-colored border wall in front of them, that corrugated monstrosity. They marvel. Then a U.S. Border Patrol vehicle starts driving past the screen. On guard, it seems, for anyone trying to cross in the opposite direction. To this, the camera woman's speaker. again, as if she's talking directly to border patrol.
他们对着镜头深情地说，我们爱墨西哥。然后镜头摇向展示他们面前铁锈色的边境墙，那个波纹状的庞然大物。他们惊叹不已。接着一辆美国边境巡逻队的车辆从屏幕前驶过。似乎是在戒备任何试图朝反方向越境的人。对此，女摄影机的发言人。再次，好像她是在直接与边境巡逻队对话。
Get them, boys, she says. Then they begin their walk into Mexico. In Los Algodonis, there are dense clusters of medical offices and a canopy of billboards above them. Vendors are set up on sidewalks where they sell handmade goods and kitchy souvenirs, like this one graphic tea that says, keep calm, you're on the fun side of Trump's wall.
她说道，抓住他们，小伙子们。然后他们开始步行进入墨西哥。在洛斯阿尔戈多尼斯，密密麻麻地分布着医疗诊所，上方是一片巨幅广告牌的树冠。小贩们在人行道上摆摊，出售手工制品和具有俗艳风格的纪念品，比如这件印有“保持冷静，你在特朗普之墙有趣的一侧”字样的特色T恤。
And then there are the street promoters. people who are stationed at almost every street corner, each of them competing for superlatives, the best deal, the quickest appointment, the most popular clinic in town. In Moeller City, a street promoter is the first person a tourist will encounter. Promontie body, what is it?
接着还有街头推销员。这些人在几乎每个街角都驻守着，每个人都在争夺最高级词汇，最好的优惠、最快的预约、镇上最受欢迎的诊所。在磨牙城，街头推销员是游客遇到的第一类人。宣传身体，那是什么？
Dental pharmacy, glasses. I got dental promotions. Some promoters try to lure people in with discounts. Others vie for attention in more creative ways, like dressing up in a full-body tooth costume and waving a sign. Then there's Alberto, a street promoter who takes a different approach altogether. He tries to attract customers with humor. I'm always trying to make stuff fun, you know.
牙科药房，眼镜。我有牙科促销活动。一些推销员试图用折扣来诱惑人们。另一些则以更有创意的方式争夺注意力，比如穿上全身牙齿服装并挥舞着标语。还有阿尔贝托，一个完全采取不同方法的街头推销员。他试图用幽默来吸引顾客。你知道的，我总是试图让事情变得有趣。
Make them laugh like a comedian almost. Make them relax just for that second. Alberto is employed by a couple clinics in town. He's assigned to a specific street corner, where he stands all day and tries to make his commissions. Because I'm like at a corner, I have a lot of people that pass by. So I talk to everybody. Eight hours out there, I'm over.
几乎像喜剧演员一样让他们发笑。让他们放松哪怕那一秒钟。阿尔贝托受雇于镇上的几家诊所。他被分配到一个特定的街角，整天站在那里，试图赚取他的佣金。因为我就在一个拐角处，所以有很多路过的人。所以我跟每个人说话。在那里的八个小时结束了。
I'm burning the morning. I'm talking and talking and I don't stop talking all day. He told me that street promoters can also get a little territorial with each other because they're all vying for the attention of the same Americans who walk into town. You don't need appointment. My daughter's open right now. You get that service right away. We're not working with appointments.
我在消耗早晨。我一直在说话，说个不停，整天都不停地说话。他告诉我，街头推销员之间也会有点地盘意识，因为他们都在争夺走进镇上的那群美国人的注意力。你不需要预约。我女儿现在开着门。你马上就能得到那种服务。我们不接受预约。
From anybody, what is it? I did all day. I talk, done stuff all day. And I still have an energy left. Alberto loves to talk. When I told him I wanted to talk about Mueller City, he was like, how much time do you have? He told me how one time he was on the phone with a girlfriend
从任何人那里，那是什么？我一整天都在做。我说话，整天都在做事情。我还有精力。阿尔贝托喜欢说话。当我告诉他我想聊聊磨牙城时，他的反应是：你有多少时间？他告诉我，有一次他和女朋友在电话里聊天
for a whole 24 hours, standing at a pay phone for an entire day, just talking. From this anecdote alone, I got the impression that Alberto, was probably good at his job, or at least that he had the stamina to endure it. Well, maybe let's not aim for 24 hours, but I'd love to chat a little bit. Alberto grew up nearby, and over the course of his life, he's seen how Los Algodonis transformed into Molar City. Being in the border, we have this, we have America.
整整 24 小时，在公用电话旁站了一整天，只是在聊天。仅从这个轶事中，我得到的印象是，阿尔贝托可能很擅长他的工作，或者至少他有忍耐这份工作的毅力。好吧，也许我们不要把目标定在 24 小时，但我很乐意聊上一会儿。阿尔贝托在附近长大，在他的一生中，他见证了洛斯阿尔戈多尼斯如何蜕变成磨牙城。身处边境，我们拥有这个，我们拥有美国。
America is very influential. America really affects everything that happens to. to the people right here. Los Algodonis has built itself up to serve the dental needs of Americans and Canadians. And the town has become wildly successful in this goal. But Algodonis went through many reinventions before it became Molar City.
美国非常具有影响力。美国确实影响着发生的一切。对这里的人们。洛斯阿尔戈多尼斯的发展是为了满足美国人和加拿大人的牙科需求。而且该镇在这一目标上取得了巨大的成功。但在变成磨牙城之前，阿尔戈多尼斯经历了多次重塑。
And I wanted to understand how it all happened. And why? Los Algodones means cotton, in plural. And that's because commercial cotton farming is what this land was once known for, back when it was still vibrant and green. Then a series of policy changes depleted the soil and dammed the flow of the Colorado River into Mexico. By the 60s, riverbeds were drying up and crops were struggling. But many Mexican border towns have long had another thriving
我想了解这一切是如何发生的。以及为什么？洛斯阿尔戈多尼斯在复数形式中是棉花的意思。那是因为商业棉花种植曾经是这片土地广为人知的原因，当时它依然充满生机和郁郁葱葱。后来，一系列政策变动耗尽了土壤，并阻断了科罗拉多河流入墨西哥的水流。到了 60 年代，河床日渐干涸，农作物举步维艰。但许多墨西哥边境城镇长期以来拥有另一个蓬勃发展的
business, booze. And after the farming industry crumbled, that's what Los Algodonis relied on. At one point, the town had 48 bars. American soldiers living on military bases in Yuma, Arizona were regulars. Alberto spent his childhood in Yuma, too. Yeah, we go to Al-Gadonis and get drunk. But yeah, that's what Agadonis has been to me from the beginning. It was a little town. Algernadona was a very small town with lots of cantinas.
行业，酒类。在农业崩溃后，这就是洛斯阿尔戈多尼斯所依赖的。一度，这个小镇拥有 48 家酒吧。居住在亚利桑那州尤马军事基地的美国士兵是这里的常客。阿尔贝托的童年也是在尤马度过的。是的，我们去阿尔戈多尼斯喝得酩酊大醉。但是是的，从一开始这就是阿尔戈多尼斯对我的意义。它是个小镇。阿尔格纳多纳是一个有着很多小酒馆的非常小的镇子。
And used to come people from Yuma to dance in the cantinas or drink. This is Dr. Jesus Medina. He moved to town fresh out of med school in 1973, and he's been working here as a doctor ever since, although he seems to be perpetually on the brink of retirement. I think when they have to retire, and my son's gentleman, when are you going to retire? Why is until you're young to retire?
尤马的人们过去常常来这里的小酒馆跳舞或喝酒。这是赫苏斯·梅迪纳医生。他在 1973 年刚从医学院毕业就搬到了镇上，从那以后他就一直在这里当医生，尽管他似乎总是处于退休的边缘。我想当他们不得不退休时，我儿子的绅士问：你打算什么时候退休？为什么直到你年轻时才退休？
Dr. Medina first learned about Los Algodonis from his brother-in-law, Dr. Bernardo Magagna, who's often described as the god-remoner, father of Moeller City. He was the first dentist from this town, you know. Maganya's now in his 80s. He is retired and didn't want to be interviewed. But Medina told me about how his brother-in-law, Magania, first had this vision to transform
梅迪纳医生最早是从他的连襟伯纳多·马加尼亚医生那里得知洛斯阿尔戈多尼斯的，后者常被称为磨牙城之父。你知道，他是这个小镇的第一位牙医。马加尼亚现在已经 80 多岁了。他已经退休，不接受采访。但梅迪纳告诉我，他的连襟马加尼亚是如何首次萌生出将
the town into a dental mecca. Back in the 60s, Maganya and Medina were living together in a city about 25 miles from Algodonis. Magania was a young dentist looking for a place to set up his private practice. At the time, he was working for someone who already had a few American patients, patients who likely lived in the South and would cross into Mexico to take advantage of lower prices. Latham started to tell about algonas. He says, why you don't move to algonas? Because algonas is four minutes from Yuma.
小镇改造为牙科麦加的愿景的。早在 60 年代，马加尼亚和梅迪纳一起住在距离阿尔戈多尼斯大约 25 英里的一座城市里。马加尼亚是一名年轻的牙医，正在寻找一个地方建立他的私人诊所。当时，他为某位已经拥有一些美国病人的医生工作，这些病人很可能是住在南部并会越境进入墨西哥以利用更低价格的人。拉萨开始讲述阿尔戈多尼斯的情况。他说，你为什么不搬到阿尔戈多尼斯去？因为阿尔戈多尼斯距离尤马只有四分钟车程。
If you go there, you're going to have a lot more patients. At first, Magania was skeptical. He paid Los Algodonis a visit, and it was a lot like he. expected, a sleepy little place with a lot of mostly drunk people. But many of those drunk people were Americans. Its proximity to the border meant there was already a culture of coming and going. He saw the Americans spending their money at the bars and thought maybe they'd spend money on dentistry too. Magania knew he could offer them a price lower than what they could get in America. And my brother-in-law, he got the idea and says, I'm going to put an office in Nogal. And he put the office. And he put the office.
如果你去那里，你将拥有更多的病人。起初，马加尼亚对此持怀疑态度。他去洛斯阿尔戈多尼斯参观了一次，它非常像他。预期的那样，一个沉睡的小地方，有着许多大多喝醉了的人。但那些醉汉中有很多是美国人。它靠近边境意味着这里已经存在一种来来往往的文化。他看到美国人在酒吧里花钱，便想也许他们也会在牙科上花钱。马加尼亚知道他可以提供比美国更低的价格。我的连襟想出了这个主意，并说：“我要在诺加莱斯开个诊所。”他建起了诊所。他建起了诊所。
and he grows so fast, and he had so many patients, so many patients. Magagna set up his clinic right across the street from the border crossing. On his first day, he saw nine patients. And for the first three years, he was the town's only dentist, sometimes working from six in the morning until 11 at night. The demand for health services ended up being so much more than he could handle on his own. So he started asking others to come set up shop, including Dr. Medina.
它发展得如此之快，他拥有如此多的病人，那么多的病人。马加尼亚将他的诊所开在了过境点马路对面。第一天，他看了九个病人。在头三年里，他是镇上唯一的牙医，有时从早上六点一直工作到晚上十I点。对医疗服务的需求结果证明远远超出了他自己所能应付的程度。于是他开始邀请其他人来这里开设诊所，其中包括梅迪纳医生。
And then I have the idea to come and practice right here. Magania helped Medina acquire a small office for his practice. He gave me a key. He says, take this, what? Go to my office and see. And then I come and I see, he made me a very small office, you know, two rooms, waiting room and the office to give attention, a table or desk.
然后我萌生了来这里行医的想法。马加尼亚帮梅迪纳为他的诊所购置了一间小办公室。他给了我一把钥匙。他说，拿着这个，什么？去我的办公室看看。然后我来了并看到了，他给我弄了一间非常小的办公室，你知道的，两个房间，候诊室和看诊的办公室，一张桌子或书桌。
and that was my first practice office I have, you know. Medina remembers those early days with amazement. Once, he stepped out of his office to see a line of people, Americans, all waiting for an appointment with him. He wasn't even taking appointments. He says the demand was immediate. And I started to work and I start to see American people, you know, hard time because I don't speak too much English,
你知道，那就是我的第一间诊所办公室。梅迪纳对那些早期的日子记忆犹新，充满了惊叹。有一次，他走出办公室，看到一排人，都是美国人，都在排队等候找他看病。他甚至不接受预约。他说需求是即时的。我开始工作，我开始看到美国人，你知道的，那段日子很艰难，因为我不会说太多英语，
but I don't kill nobody, no. Magania and Medina were treating patients who would talk about their struggles with health care in America. For most Americans, dental care has always been out of reach.
但我没有弄死任何人，没有。马加尼亚和梅迪纳治疗的病人们经常谈论他们在美医疗保健方面的困境。对大多数美国人来说，牙科护理一直都是遥不可及的。
Early dentistry was considered more of a craftsman's trade. Dental work was performed by barbers and blacksmiths, people who were considered quacks by the larger medical field. And ever since then, dentistry and general medicine
早期的牙科被更多地视为一种工匠手艺。牙科工作由理发师和铁匠执行，这些人被更广阔的医学界视为江湖郎中。从那时起，牙科和普通医学
have fought hard to keep themselves separate. Cut to today, and dental and health care are still separated. They have separate insurances, separate teaching schools, separate medical records even. It's as if matters of the mouth are separate from the body. But of course, they're not. Every year, hundreds of thousands of Americans end up in emergency rooms for something like a toothache, something that could have been treated in a dental office.
一直在努力保持彼此分离。转到今天，牙科和医疗保健仍然是分开的。它们有单独的保险、单独的教学学校，甚至单独的病历。就好像口腔问题与身体是分离的。但当然，它们并非如此。每年，成千上万的美国人最终因牙痛之类的本可以在牙科诊所得到治疗的事情而涌入急诊室。
But most ERs don't have on-call dentists. so often these patients are sent home with painkillers and are told to go visit their dentist. But a lot of these people don't have dentists, or if they do, the cost for a visit is impossibly high. And yet, people are held personally accountable for the state of their teeth in ways that they're not held accountable for many other health conditions. Poor dental care can be both life-threatening and humiliating. As if unhealthy teeth are a failure of individual responsibility, rather than the symptom of a broken system.
但大多数急诊室没有值班牙医。因此，这些病人经常带着止痛药被送回家，并被告知去看牙医。但这些人中的许多人没有牙医，或者如果有的话，看病的费用高得离谱。然而，人们对牙齿状况要承担个人责任，而这种责任在许多其他健康状况中是不要求的。糟糕的牙科护理既可能危及生命，又会让人感到羞辱。就好像不健康的牙齿是个人责任的失败，而不是破碎体制的症状。
In Algodonis, Dr. Magania saw the state of dental care in America as an opportunity to turn this small Mexican border town into a place full of dental services catered to desperate Americans and Canadians looking for deep discounts. But the town was still mostly strip clubs and bars, and he felt like that was holding them back. So in 1980, Magania became mayor, although the technically accurate term is municipal delegate. As municipal delegate, Magania shuttered most of the cantinas.
在阿尔戈多尼斯，马加尼亚医生将美国牙科护理的现状视为一个机会，把这个墨西哥小边境镇变成一个充满牙科服务的地方，专门迎合那些寻找巨额折扣、绝望的美国和加拿大人。但这个小镇仍然主要是脱衣舞俱乐部和酒吧，他觉得这拖了他们的后腿。因此，在 1980 年，马加尼亚成为市长，尽管技术上准确的称谓是市镇代表。作为市镇代表，马加尼亚关闭了大部分的小酒馆。
It was his first major step in transforming algodonis into molar city. Year after year, the same buildings that housed those cantinas gave way to more clinics and pharmacies. In cantingas, I don't have there no more, only one or two in Algodonis, you know. But they disappear almost, you know. If we drink, we drink in home. All can'tinas are dental offices now. Magania helped transform the town in other ways, too. He opened a middle school, a high school, and a dental school.
这是他将阿尔戈多尼斯改造为磨牙城的第一大步。年复一年，容纳那些小酒馆的同一栋栋建筑让位给了更多的诊所和药房。在阿尔戈多尼斯，我不再有那些小酒馆了，你知道的，只剩一两家。但它们几乎消失了，你知道的。如果我们喝酒，我们在家里喝。所有的小酒馆现在都是牙科诊所了。马加尼亚还在其他方面帮助改造了小镇。他开办了一所初中、一所高中和一所牙科学校。
And Dr. Medina, like his brother-in-law, also got involved in town leadership. He coached the local sports teams. And he became the town's first official delegate of tourism. And when I come, we make the revolution right here, you know. More and more healthcare professionals were migrating to Algodonis, and among Americans, knowledge of the town's services was spreading, although mostly by word of mouth. Still, Dr. Medina was looking for a way to take Algodonis to the next level. And so he decided to attract people to their reformed party town by throwing a giant party,
梅迪纳医生也像他的连襟一样，参与到了小镇的领导工作中。他执教了当地的运动队。并成为了该镇第一位官方旅游代表。当我来的时候，我们在正这里发起了一场革命，你知道的。越来越多的医疗保健专业人员移民到阿尔戈多尼斯，在美国人中间，关于小镇服务的知识正在传播，尽管主要通过口碑。尽管如此，梅迪纳医生仍在寻找将阿尔戈多尼斯提升到一个新水平的方法。因此，他决定通过举办一场盛大的派对来吸引人们来到他们这个经过改造的派对小镇，
a party specifically for snowbirds, a term for retired Americans and Canadians who migrate south every year following the sun. Come on over, Medina advertised. We'll have free margaritas, free Viagra, discounted root canals. When kind of did you start this? Wait a minute because I forgot. Right here is when they gave me the position,
一个专门为候鸟族举办的派对，候鸟族是指每年随太阳向南迁徙的退休美国人和加拿大人的称呼。梅迪纳宣传说，来吧。我们将提供免费玛格丽特酒、免费伟哥、打折根管治疗。你是什么时候开始这个的？等一下，因为我忘了。正是在这里，他们给了我这个职位，
you know, in the newspaper of Mexicali. Dr. Medina is sitting in his office, flipping through an old photo album that he's holding up to our Zoom screen. It's full of newspaper clippings and pictures of all the parties he threw over the years. His first one was in 1987. 7,000 tourists showed up. In the photos, they're all crammed into the town's four square blocks.
你知道的，在墨卡利报纸上。梅迪纳医生坐在他的办公室里，翻阅着一本旧相册，他把它举到我们的 Zoom 屏幕前。里面满是对他多年来举办的所有派对的剪报和照片。他的第一场派对是在 1987 年。7000 名游客出现了。照片里，他们全都挤在镇上的四个街区里。
Many are holding red solo cups. This was my first party. Look at the American people. How I do it? Just in the street, you know, I don't have places to do it. Medina flips through the book fondly. as if he's cooing at baby photos. And that's the way alcohol is to start, you know, with that.
许多人拿着红色的独奏红杯。这是我的第一场派对。看看美国人。我是怎么做到的？你知道的，就在街上，我没有地方做这个。梅迪纳深情地翻看着这本书。就好像他在对着婴儿照片发出呢喃。这就是酒精开始的方式，你知道的，就是那样。
And like this, you can see all my book is full of parties, you know, till I go and everything, you know. Well, it's all my life in this book, you know. It's clear that Medina put his heart into these parties into making the town grow the way it did. He convinced his neighbors to cook enough food to feed thousands for free. He hired a mariachi band and converted an old boxing ring into a stage. And the Americans had a great time.
就这样，你可以看到我的整本书都充满了派对，你知道，直到我去还有一切，你知道。好吧，我的一生都在这本书里，你知道。很显然，梅迪纳倾注了心血举办这些派对，让小镇以现在的方式发展。他游说邻居们做足够的食物，免费喂饱数千人。他雇了一支玛利亚奇乐队，并将一个旧拳击台改造成了舞台。美国人们玩得很开心。
Medina made sure the margaritas were strong. And they was drunk like crazy. You know, the American customs told me, Dr. Medina, what do you get to those guys? Why? They cross right here. They don't want to show the papers. They tell a son of a bitch.
梅迪纳确保玛格丽特酒很烈。他们疯狂地喝醉了。你知道的，美国海关人员告诉我，梅迪纳医生，你给那些家伙吃了什么？为什么？他们就在这里过境。他们不想出示文件。他们骂了个混蛋。
They was very drunk. Year after year, Los Algodonis would continue to throw parties like that first one. Americans would return home, talk of the tacos, the town, their teeth. What was once a town of about 750 when Magania first arrived is now crammed with clinics, hotels, restaurants, and pharmacies. Today, young dentists and souvenir vendors from all over Mexico continue to migrate to town in hopes of finding stable work. And the tourists keep coming in droves. In winter, it's too much people. And they make lines. And that's the uncomfortable for them.
他们喝得烂醉。年复一年，洛斯阿尔戈多尼斯继续举办像第一次那样的派对。美国人会回到家乡，谈论塔可卷、小镇和他们的牙齿。当马加尼亚刚到达时，这个大约有 750 人的小镇现在挤满了诊所、酒店、餐馆和药房。今天，来自墨西哥各地的年轻牙医和纪念品小贩源源不断地迁往小镇，希望能找到稳定的工作。游客们仍然成群结天地涌来。在冬天，人太多了。他们排起了长队。这对他们来说很不舒服。
But they don't care. They make the lines, you know. And they still coming because they find dental services good, a good price and everything. And very handsome doctors. We live from the tourists, you know. We live from the tourists. It's a sentiment I heard from everyone in town. Teenagers will run to the border after school to sell trinkets to people
但他们不在乎。你知道的，他们排队。他们还是会来，因为他们发现牙科服务很好，价格合理，应有尽有。而且医生很帅。我们靠游客生活，你知道的。我们靠游客生活。这是我从镇上每个人那里听到的心声。青少年放学后会跑向边境，向人们兜售小饰品
waiting in line to go home. Women will walk up and down the line selling handmade sweaters and hot meals. And on the American side, the Quitson tribe manages a casino resort. It's a popular spot for dental tourists who try their hand at the slot machines
在排队回家的队伍中。妇女们会顺着队伍走来走去，兜售手工毛衣和热食。在美国一侧，奎森部落管理着一家赌场度假村。对于那些在两次预约之间尝试在老虎机上碰碰运气的牙科游客来说，这是一个很受欢迎的地方。
in between appointments. I think Adonis is a good town. It's become a better town than it was before. You know, we really don't have a lot of, like, serenic views or, like, anything touristic.
我认为阿尔戈多尼斯是个不错的城镇。它已经变得比以前更好了。你知道，我们真的没有很多，比如风景如画的景色，或者类似旅游景点的东西。
but the people are really like, they're really like hardworking people and, and they're also, they like to party, you know, they like to have good times also. Street promoter Alberto moved back to the area eight years ago, in part to be closer to his family after a road accident in Cancun made it difficult for him to walk. He told me he gets discounted dental care from the clinics that employ him, but he's been putting off amputating his leg for years because of the cost of surgery. We vary anywhere from $120 to some of us. Some of those are making like $5 or $800 a week. I asked Alberto what he thought about the town's transformation into Molar City. I think dental has helped Algodonians a lot, but I think people just like their money and they go somewhere else, you know?
但这里的人真的很像，他们真的很像勤劳的人，而且，他们也喜欢聚会，你知道，他们也喜欢过得开心。街头推销员阿尔贝托八年前搬回了这个地区，部分原因是在坎昆发生的一场车祸使他难以行走后，能离家人更近一些。他告诉我，他从雇佣他的诊所获得了打折的牙科护理，但由于手术费用昂贵，他多年来一直推迟截肢手术。我们各不相同，从 120 美元到我们中的一些人不等。其中一些人一周能赚 5 或 800 美元。我问阿尔贝托他对小镇变成磨牙城有什么看法。我认为牙科对阿尔戈多尼斯帮助很大，但我认为人们只是喜欢他们的钱，他们会去别的地方，你知道吗？
They go live it up somewhere else. Because a lot of these doctors have become millionaires. Many of those original dentists live in mansions, complete with indoor courtyards and pools. In addition to their dental practice, certain families in town own many of the hotels, restaurants, and pharmacies here. But zoom out of the town center, and you'll see mostly unpaved roads and humble homes. There's this 18th century paleontologist, Georges Cuvier. He has this famous quote about teeth. Show me your teeth, he said.
他们去别的地方过上好日子了。因为这些医生中有很多已经成了百万富翁。许多最初的牙医住在豪宅里，里面配有室内庭院和游泳池。除了他们的牙科诊所之外，镇上的某些家族还拥有这里的许多酒店、餐馆和药房。但把视线从镇中心拉远，你会看到大多是未铺沥青的道路和简朴的住宅。有一位 18 世纪的古生物学家乔治·居维叶。他有一句关于牙齿的名言。他说，展示你的牙齿，
and I will tell you who you are. It's true that from teeth alone, a dental anthropologist can gather all sorts of information. They can decipher migration patterns and cultural norms. They can tell if you ate with your fingers or if you endured famine. Our teeth are biographies. They hold facts about ourselves. Facts we may not even recognize while we're alive.
我就会告诉你你是谁。确实，仅凭牙齿，牙科人类学家就能收集到各种信息。他们可以破译迁徙模式和文化规范。他们能看出你是用手指吃饭还是经历过饥荒。我们的牙齿就是自传。它们承载着关于我们自身的真相。有些真相甚至在我们活着的时候都可能没有意识到。
I'm curious how you would describe your relationship to your teeth. Yeah, my relationship with my teeth was, you know, I didn't really take the time on a big basis to have good to don't care. I haven't truly smiled in probably 10 years. This is Jeff Jackson. He's a retired veteran in his 60s.
我很想知道你会如何描述你与牙齿的关系。是的，我和牙齿的关系是，你知道的，我并没有真正在很大程度上花时间去好好护理牙齿。我已经差不多 10 年没有真正笑过了。这是杰夫·杰克逊。他是一名 60 多岁的退休退伍军人。
Jeff and his wife live in their RV, which is parked in Nevada for most of the year. Over the last couple years, Jeff started losing more and more teeth. By the time he made the decision for implants, he had 13 teeth left. My wife and I are both waiting to get those permanent teeth in. Yeah, it's just, it's going to be a fun time. Go down there and get them in and be able to enjoy it.
杰夫和他的妻子住在他们的房车里，房车一年中大部分时间都停在内华达州。在过去的几年里，杰夫开始失去越来越多的牙齿。当他决定做种植牙时，他只剩下 13 颗牙齿了。我和妻子都在等着装上那些永久性的牙齿。是的，这将会是一段快乐的时光。去那里装上它们，然后能够好好享受。
I spoke to Jeff after his second trip to Moeller City. He was planning to go back a third time to complete what's called a full mouth restoration, which is one of the more popular treatments in town. You understand why people go through it. I was like, you know, I'm just going to be an ugly old dude anyway. But the confidence booster. And not having to sell my house to do it. Jeff isn't eligible for Medicare.
我在杰夫去磨牙城的第二次旅行后采访了他。他正计划第三次回去，以完成所谓的全口重建，这是镇上最受欢迎的治疗方法之一。你能理解为什么人们会经历这一切。我想，你知道的，反正我也就是个丑陋的老家伙。但这能增强自信。而且不需要为此卖掉我的房子。杰夫不符合医疗保险的资格。
He makes too much money for Medicaid. And he couldn't find a private insurance plan with a premium he could afford. A dentist in Nevada put together a price tag of about $50,000. In Los Agadonis, he found the same tree. treatment for less than 20,000. On top of the implants themselves, that price included getting his remaining teeth pulled, the cost of his pain medication, and his hotel stay. Mexican dental work is less expensive for a couple reasons. Labor and real estate in Mexico costs a lot less than in the U.S. And dental school is heavily subsidized, meaning fewer
他的收入太高，不符合医疗补助的标准。他也找不到保费他能负担得起的私人保险计划。内华达州的一位牙医给出了大约 50,000 美元的报价。在洛斯阿尔戈多尼斯，他找到了相同的治疗。治疗费用不到 20,000 美元。除了种植牙本身，这个价格还包括拔掉剩余的牙齿、止痛药的费用以及酒店住宿。墨西哥牙科工作比较便宜有几个原因。墨西哥的劳动力和房地产成本比美国低得多。牙科学校得到大量补贴，这意味着更少的
dentists graduate school with the kind of colossal debt that's rampant in the U.S. And in Mexico, dentists don't need to get malpractice insurance. Still, it's not as though Mexican dentistry is affordable to all Mexicans. Only 48% of Mexicans nationwide who are in need of oral health care are able to receive it. But to the average American, it's a discount worth traveling for. And this trend might increase. By 2060, the number of Americans over 65 will practically double. And the U.S. will see an exploding need for all kinds of health care services in a system that won't be able to support all of its people.
牙医在毕业时背负着在美国普遍存在的巨额债务。在墨西哥，牙医不需要购买医疗事故责任险。尽管如此，这并不是说墨西哥的牙齿护理对所有墨西哥人都负担得起。在全国范围内，只有 48% 需要口腔医疗保健的墨西哥人能够得到它。但对普通美国人来说，这是一个值得为此奔波的折扣。这种趋势可能会增加。到 2060 年，65 岁以上的美国人数量将实际上翻倍。美国将看到对各种医疗保健服务的爆发式需求，而这个体制将无法支持其所有人。
People like Jeff. I'm just curious if you have any, if you have any thoughts or opinions on health care, access to health care in the U.S., you know, from your perspective, I mean, there's clearly a problem, right? I am a dive-in-the-wall capitalist kind of guy. And so I don't really buy off on socialize medicine. But we have to bring down costs. You have millions of people who can't afford health insurance. To Jeff, Mueller City might be a solution. But dental tourism is also a measurement of the problem.
像杰夫这样的人。我只是好奇你是否对美国的医疗保健、获取医疗保健的途径有任何想法或意见，从你的角度来看，我的意思是，这显然是个问题，对吧？我是一个顽固的资本主义者。所以我其实并不买账社会主义医疗。但我们必须降低成本。你有数百万负担不起医疗保险的人。对杰夫来说，磨牙城可能是一个解决方案。但牙科旅游也是衡量这个问题的一个标尺。
It shows us the lengths people must go to seek an end to their pain. More with Lasha after the break. We're back with Lasha Madon. On a typical day, dentist Myra Jimenez is buzzing around her clinic. Myra moved to Algodonis from Guadalajara two decades ago. She says her early memories there are a blur, mostly because she was so busy working. I mean, skipping meals, skipping meals, skipping everything. I mean, there were so many people.
它向我们展示了人们为了摆脱痛苦必须付出多大的努力。休息回来后，我们将带来更多关于拉沙的内容。我们欢迎拉沙·马登回归。在平常的一天里，牙医迈拉·希门尼斯在她的诊所里忙碌着。迈拉在二十年前从瓜达拉哈拉搬到阿尔戈多尼斯。她说她在那里的早期记忆一片模糊，主要是因为她忙于工作。我的意思是，不吃饭，不吃饭，什么都不吃。我的意思是，有太多人了。
I did up to 100 crowns in a single day. I was a machine. Myra told me that in those days, the streets were so packed with Americans that you couldn't get through. She was always working all day. I'm telling you from 8 in the morning to 10 p.m. This is Myra's daughter, Rennie, who works in her mom's clinic. Rennie grew up in this clinic.
我在单日内做了多达 100 个牙冠。我当时就是一台机器。迈拉告诉我，在那些日子里，街上挤满了美国人，你根本走不过去。她总是整天都在工作。我告诉你，从早上 8 点到晚上 10 点。这是迈拉的女儿雷妮，她在她妈妈的诊所工作。雷妮在这间诊所里长大。
She uses the words waiting room and living room interchangeably. Like living rooms, like the waiting areas would be packed with people just packed. And I remember I had a ride that would drop me off at the border. And one of my mom's workers would pick me up walking. So I'd come back walking to the office. And I remember my mom didn't know how to speak English. And so I remember sitting in the living room in the waiting area with patients from Canada. from Utah, from Texas, from California,
她将候诊室和起居室互换着用。就像起居室一样，候诊区挤满了人，挤得满满当当的。我记得我曾坐过车，它把我送到边境。然后我妈妈的一个员工会步行来接我。所以我就会步行回到办公室。我记得我妈妈不会说英语。所以我记得自己和来自加拿大、
and all the patients helping me do my homework every single day. Myra never expected to move up to Los Algodones, to raise her kids on the border. Her first impression was that the town was arid and boring. But Myra likes having Americans as patients. She says that they're especially grateful. Before moving to town, Myra had never met people so excited to be seeing a day.
犹他州、得克萨斯州、加利福尼亚州的患者一起坐在起居室的候诊区里，所有患者每天都在帮我做家庭作业。迈拉从没想过要搬到洛斯阿尔戈多尼斯，在边境抚养她的孩子。她最初的印象是这个小镇干旱而无聊。但迈拉喜欢美国人作为她的病人。她说他们格外感激。在搬到镇上之前，迈拉从未见过如此高兴能看牙医的人。
And what I love most is that the Americans always treated us very well. They were very grateful patients and you became friends with them. I love that. I remember being a little kid and my mom would come home with patience to my house. Oh, this is so and so. And they're going to be eating dinner with us. And I'm like, who are these people? Myra and Reni talked a lot about this sense of community fostered between dentist and patient.
我最喜欢的是美国人总是对我们非常好。他们是非常感激的病人，你会和他们成为朋友。我喜欢这样。我记得我还是个小孩子的时候，我妈妈会带着病人回家。哦，这是某某某。他们要和我们一起吃晚饭。我想，这些人是谁？迈拉和雷妮谈了很多关于牙医和患者之间培养出的这种社区感。
But Myra also has concerns about the industry. In fact, there's one thing that it seems like almost everyone is constantly worried about. That the town stays safe. And more importantly, that the town is perceived as safe. Violence and organized crime is a real problem in the Mexican borderlands. but medical tourists are rarely targeted. Still, one dental coordinator told me that trying to quell concerns about safety
但迈拉也对这个行业有担忧。事实上，有一件事似乎几乎每个人都在不断担心。那就是小镇保持安全。更重要的是，这个小镇被认为是一个安全的地方。暴力和有组织犯罪是墨西哥边境地区的一个真实问题。但医疗游客很少成为目标。尽管如此，一位牙科协调员告诉我，试图消除对安全的担忧
is a major part of her job. She told me that her American clients bring it up all the time. I think because Mexico has, you know, a bad reputation in the U.S. and everybody thinking coming into Mexico is dangerous. I have people thinking that,
是她工作的一个重要部分。她告诉我，她的美国客户总是提起这件事。我想是因为墨西哥在 美国有一个坏名声，每个人都认为来墨西哥是危险的。我有人认为，
oh, we're going to come to Mexico and we're going to be waiting here with guns and stuff like that. But... People have told you that. Yeah. They're like, oh, I thought it was going to be the cartel outside. And I'm like, no, it's very safe.
哦，我们要去墨西哥，然后我们会在那里遇到拿着枪之类东西的人等着。但是……有人对你这么说过吗？是的。他们会说，哦，我以为外面会有贩毒集团。而我会说，不，这里非常安全。
And they're very scared. But I think it's more because of the news. More than real incidents of violence and crime, people working in Algodonis are concerned about how Mexico is portrayed in American media. The news comes out that there's going to be a shootout. that they're going to kidnap you, that if you cross to Mexico, you're in danger, that your life is in danger?
他们非常害怕。但我认为这更多是因为新闻。比起暴力和犯罪的真实事件，在阿尔戈多尼斯工作的人更关心墨西哥在美国媒体中的形象。新闻出来说会有枪战。他们会绑架你，如果你越境去墨西哥，你就处于危险之中，你的生命处于危险之中？
Yes, I think that affects us. I think most people, they're a little scared to come to Mexico because the histories they hear in the United States, you know, whose they can steal them right here or they can do something, shotguns and things like that, mafia guys, whatever, you know. Los Agadones itself is actually a, a pretty safe place to visit. But still, the town works so hard to correct the narrative that many Americans have about Mexico. Their livelihoods depend on it. The industry is having to put a lot
是的，我认为这会影响我们。我认为大多数人，他们有点害怕来墨西哥，因为他们在美国听到的故事，你知道的，他们可以在这里偷走他们或者他们可以做点什么，散弹枪之类的事情，黑手党家伙，随便什么，你知道的。洛斯阿尔戈多尼斯本身其实是一个非常安全，值得一游的地方。即便如此，小镇仍在努力纠正许多美国人对墨西哥的成见。他们的生计取决于此。这个行业不得不投入大量
effort and spend a lot of money and make lower profits than they might otherwise if they didn't have to put so much effort into dealing with that narrative or those prejudiced assumptions about Mexico. This is Christina Adams. Christina's a public health researcher who studied the ethics of dental tourism in Los Algodones. She wanted to know how the industry might be affecting locals. I think it's completely normal for someone leaving their home country and accessing health care to be questioning, you know, is this safe? What are the standards of care in this different country? And then I think there's another layer on top of that where I think they're also trying to combat really prejudiced assumptions about Mexico as much as possible, that it's, you know,
精力，花很多钱，并获得比他们原本可能获得的更低的利润，如果他们不必花这么多精力去处理这种叙事或对墨西哥的那些偏见假设的话。这是克里斯蒂娜·亚当斯。克里斯蒂娜是一名公共卫生研究员，她研究了洛斯阿尔戈多尼斯牙科旅游的伦理。她想知道这个行业可能会如何影响当地人。我认为对于一个离开祖国并获得医疗保健的人来说，质疑“这安全吗？这个不同国家的护理标准是什么？”是完全正常的。然后我认为在此之上还有另一层，我认为他们也在尽最大可能消除对墨西哥作为全球南方国家、
a country from the global south, that it's underdeveloped or even undeveloped, that there's no way the standards could be as high of quality in a place like Mexico. Christina says that clinics in Algodonis employ certain strategies to maintain a positive reputation with tourists. Some clinics will pay medical tourism companies in other countries to act as a middleman between patient and clinic. Many of these companies are based in Europe, and they'll put Mexican clinics through a vetting process to prove their legitimacy to a non-Mexican clientele. When making interior design choices, clinics might consider an American aesthetic, whatever that means. The goal is to make sure the image of Mexican dental care is squeaky clean.
是不发达甚至未开发的国家的真正偏见假设，即在墨西哥这样一个地方，标准绝对不可能像那样高质量。克里斯蒂娜说，阿尔戈多尼斯的诊所采用某些策略来维持在游客中的积极声誉。一些诊所会向其他国家的医疗旅游公司支付费用，充当患者和诊所之间的中间人。其中许多公司总部设在欧洲，它们会对墨西哥诊所进行审查过程，以向非墨西哥客户证明其合法性。在进行室内设计选择时，诊所可能会考虑美国审美，无论那意味着什么。目标是确保墨西哥牙科护理的形象一尘不染。
Sometimes, quite literally, Christina remembers being hit by the intense smell of sanitizer when she walked into the many clinics in town. It was overwhelming sometimes walking into a dental clinic, just the smell of sanitization. Like, it feels like above and beyond anything I'd ever experienced myself walking into health care spaces. Like they're really trying to make sure you smell and notice right away. Like, this is clean. All this effort is to make Los Algodones feel safe and comfortable, relatable even. And so there are ways in which the town has worked to play up its Americanness by minimizing
有时，字面意思上，克里斯蒂娜记得当她走进镇上的众多诊所时，她被强烈的消毒剂气味扑鼻而来。走进牙科诊所有时气味太浓烈了，仅仅是消毒的气味。就像，感觉超出了我曾经亲身经历过的走进医疗空间的任何体验。就像他们真的在试图确保你闻到并立即注意到。就像，这很干净。所有这些努力都是为了让洛斯阿尔戈多尼斯感觉安全舒适，甚至有亲切感。因此，小镇在某些方面通过最大程度地减少
its Mexicansness. I definitely remember this sense of like staff being told to minimize their Mexican accents because that would help people, tourists feel more comfortable. Christina's research also found that some clinics would hire someone who speaks American English to just sit in the waiting room. The idea being that their presence might help nervous Americans feel more at ease. It seems like everyone who lives and works in town has their own strategy to calm anxious American nerves. One local dental tourism company uses a camera to occasionally live stream the border crossing from a bird's eye view. These videos exist almost as if to say, see, it's so uneventful here.
其墨西哥性，来发挥其美国性。我绝对记得这种感觉，比如员工被告知要尽量减少他们的墨西哥口音，因为那会帮助人们、游客感到更舒适。克里斯蒂娜的研究还发现，一些诊所会雇用一个说美式英语的人只是坐在候诊室里。这个想法是，他们的存在可能会帮助紧张的美国人感到更自在。似乎每个在镇上生活和工作的人都有自己的策略来平息美国游客焦虑的神经。当地一家牙科旅游公司使用摄像头偶尔从鸟瞰视角直播边境交界处。这些视频的存在几乎就像是在说，看，这里太风平浪静了。
Boring, in fact. Safe. Back when Dr. Jesus Medina was head of the tourism department in the 80s, he developed his own strategy to make skeptical U.S. tourists feel comfortable in a Mexican dental clinic. He created a complaint office, a place tourists could go if they felt like they were being scammed. He called it the Office of Defense of the Tourists. That way, if one Mexican doctor do a bad job to one of the patients, they can go to that office, you know? And then we call the doctor and we make them give the money back to the
事实上很无聊。安全。早在 80 年代赫苏斯·梅迪纳医生担任旅游部负责人时，他就制定了自己的策略，让怀疑的美国游客在墨西哥牙科诊所感到舒适。他设立了一个投诉办公室，供游客在觉得自己被骗时前往。他称之为“游客防卫办公室”。这样，如果一个墨西哥医生对其中一个病人做得很糟糕，他们可以去那个办公室，你知道吗？然后我们打电话给医生，让他们把钱退给
patients, you know. The office functioned like an amateur courtroom, and Medina enlisted Dr. Magania as the judge. Magania would inspect the dental work of other Mexican dentists, occasionally calling the police in for backup. It was very hard, you know. We seen the police and comes there. And Maragnan says, your work is not good. You have to give the money back to the lady.
病人，你知道的。该办公室的运作就像一个业余法庭，梅迪纳将马加尼亚医生招募为法官。马加尼亚会检查其他墨西哥牙医的牙科工作，偶尔还会打电话给警察寻求支援。这非常困难，你知道的。我们看到警察来了。马加尼亚说，你的工作不好。你必须把钱退给这位女士。
Police in Los Algodones exist to protect the industry and to make tourists feel safe. There's an old promotional video for Moeller City still up on YouTube. It's from 12 years ago and it's less than a minute long. In the clip, a police officer
洛斯阿尔戈多尼斯的警察存在的目的，是为了保护这个行业，并让游客感到安全。YouTube 上仍然挂着一个关于磨牙城的旧宣传视频。那是 12 年前的，时长不到一分钟。在剪辑中，一名警官
does a salsa twirl with an elderly white woman. The video is titled, All Tourists Are Safe and Fun in Los Agodonis. There's parties, there's fun, there's bars, there's cheap food and drinks, there's dental care, there's a ton of pharmaceuticals, and the police are watching. If there's any sense of like any trouble brewing, police will be very much on it. Police might help tourists feel safe, but for locals, especially low-wage workers like street vendors and promoters, the police ensure that their movements are more. tightly controlled. Remember those famous welcome parties, the ones that Dr. Medina started in the 80s?
与一位年迈的白人女性跳着萨尔萨舞转圈。该视频标题为“所有游客在洛斯阿尔戈多尼斯都是安全和有趣的”。这里有派对，有乐趣，有酒吧，有便宜的食物和饮料，有牙科护理，有大量的药物，而且警察在注视着。如果有任何酝酿麻烦的迹象，警察会非常迅速地介入。警察可能会让游客感到安全，但对于当地人，尤其是像街头小贩和推销员这样的低薪工人来说，警察确保了他们的活动受到更严格的控制。还记得那些著名的欢迎派对吗？就是梅迪纳医生在 80 年代开创的那些派对？
A lot of locals aren't invited. In fact, they're explicitly told to stay away. There's a lot of expectations around where people are allowed to be on those days. Like, you know, definitely do not show up at the party unless you're helping to work there. And so on a day like the welcome party, that involves sort of restricting the movement
许多当地人并没有被邀请。事实上，他们被明确告知不要靠近。在那些日子里，对于人们被允许出现在哪里有许多期望。比如，你知道的，绝对不要出现在派对上，除非你在那里帮忙工作。因此，在像欢迎派对这样的一天，这涉及到某种限制
of other folks who live there and making sure that they're only seeing and experiencing what the sort of town elites want them to see an experience to ensure that the reputation of the tourist industry is upheld. Despite all this effort towards safety, whenever violence does occur anywhere in the border region,
当地其他居民的活动，并确保他们只看到和体验镇上的精英们希望他们看到和体验的东西，以确保旅游业的声誉得以维护。尽管为了安全做出了所有这些努力，但无论边界地区的什么地方发生暴力事件，
it can have major ripple effects on medical tourism. I spoke to someone named David Vecuist, a medical tourism researcher who conducted a bunch of sources surveys on Americans after an incident in 2023 when four American medical tourists were ambushed by a drug cartel and only two of them survived. David was curious about Americans perceived ideas about safety in Mexico and how those ideas might impact their decision to engage in medical tourism there. On one of his surveys,
它都可能对医疗旅游产生巨大的连锁反应。我采访了一个名叫大卫·韦奎斯特（David Vecuist）的人，他是一名医疗旅游研究人员，在2023年发生了一起四名美国医疗游客遭到贩毒集团伏击且只有两人幸存的事件后，他对美国人进行了多次调查。大卫很好奇美国人对墨西哥安全的看法，以及这些看法可能会如何影响他们在当地进行医疗旅游的决定。在他的其中一项调查中，
he asked Americans, would you feel safe going to Mexico? And then another question. Would you feel safe going to Cancun? David's research suggested that Americans perceive Mexico and Cancun as two separate places. Cancun is safe. Mexico is not. In a way,
他问美国人，去墨西哥你觉得安全吗？然后是另一个问题。去坎昆你觉得安全吗？大卫的研究表明，美国人将墨西哥和坎昆视为两个不同的地方。坎昆是安全的。墨西哥则不是。某种程度上，
I think Los Agodonis has achieved that Cancun status. Moeller City can exist as a performance for American consumers, disembodied from the forces that created it. And about how many people do you think in town have the same?
我认为洛斯阿尔戈多尼斯已经达到了坎昆那样的地位。莫勒城可以作为一种为美国消费者表演的场景存在，脱离了创造它的力量。你觉得镇上有多少人有和你一样的
kind of job that you do. Oh, my competitions. Does it feel like competition? Well, I got them all, you know, I got them all pulling it out. I got a report on every single one of them. Which one would you want me to start with? I got my competition is everywhere. Everybody's my competition.
那种工作？哦，我的竞争对手。这感觉像是竞争吗？嗯，我把他们都摸透了，你知道的，我都了解。我对他们每个人都有所掌握。你想让我从哪一个开始说起？我的竞争对手无处不在。每个人都是我的竞争对手。
There are dozens of street promoters like Alberto. And because there are so many of them, all working on commission, Alberto's success depends on his charisma. He has to give the best performance. And so, Alberto has his own strategies to try to stand out and make a good impression. Besides workshopping comedic material on the job, he told me this one other thing.
像阿尔韦托这样的街头推销员有几十个。正因为有这么多人，而且都是拿佣金的，阿尔韦托的成功取决于他的个人魅力。他必须奉献出最精彩的表演。因此，阿尔韦托有他自己的一套策略，试图脱颖而出并留下好印象。除了在工作中琢磨喜剧素材，他还告诉我另一件事。
He tends to play up how American he is. It's not a hard thing for him to do, because like many people who grew up along the border, Alberto traveled back and forth a lot. He lived in Arizona, but crossed the border weekly. His English is good. He describes himself as being from the border.
他倾向于表现得自己有多么美国化。对他来说这并不难，因为像许多在边境长大的孩子一样，阿尔韦托经常来回奔波。他住在亚利桑那州，但每周都要穿梭边境。他的英语很好。他形容自己是来自边境的人。
So I grew up going to school and then coming down the weekends down to Mexico. And a lot of kids grow up like that. Because there's a lot of people in Aguadoronis. They were, oh, I forgot to mention this. I was deported. Alberto was deported to Mexico in 2010. In fact, I learned that almost. all of Moeller City's street promoters are deportees.
所以我从小就去上学，然后在周末回到墨西哥。很多孩子都是这样长大的。因为阿尔戈多尼斯有很多人。他们，哦，我忘了提这个。我被驱逐出境了。阿尔韦托于2010年被驱逐出境到墨西哥。事实上，我了解到几乎莫勒城的所有街头推销员都是被驱逐出境者。
It is, in fact, their Americanness, their American English, that makes them ideal candidates for this role. It helps me break the eyes. It helps me bond with people. Right away, they can tell that I lived in America. Oh, they bring it out. Yeah, they'll say it like that. They'll be like, oh, I can hear you all.
事实上，正是他们的美国属性——他们的美式英语——使他们成为这个角色的理想人选。这有助于我打破坚冰。这有助于我与人们建立联系。他们马上就能看出我在美国生活过。哦，他们会说出来的。是的，他们会这样说：‘哦，我能听出来。’
You live in space. Oh, like, yes. Got me a little agamication over there. So it makes them relate to them more and feel more relaxed. Alberto tells me he'll recognize familiar faces crossing in New Mexico from time to time. So-and-so from high school, his friend's uncle. But he doesn't get to see his family so often. They all live in Arizona and don't like to come visit.
‘你住在……’哦，就像：‘是的，我在那边受过一点美式教育。’这使得他们能与游客产生更多共鸣，感到更加轻松。阿尔韦托告诉我，他时不时会认出从新墨西哥州过境的熟悉面孔。高中时的某某，他朋友的叔叔。但他不常常见到他的家人。他们都住在亚利桑那州，不喜欢来探望。
They really only come when they have to. Yeah. The reason they don't like to see. like it is because of the immigration, the way they treat them. When they're crossing, they always get harassed. Yeah, when they're going back to America, they get harassed. So they get tired of that. Los Algodonis has long been set up for the benefit of Americans.
他们真的只有在不得不来的时候才会来。是的。他们不喜欢来的原因是因为移民局，以及他们对待他们的方式。当他们过境时，他们总是受到骚扰。是的，当他们返回美国时，他们会受到骚扰。所以他们对此感到厌倦了。洛斯阿尔戈多尼斯长期以来一直是为美国人的利益而建立的。
And the journey Americans take to cross into Molar City has always been a simple one. But of course, the journey in the opposite direction is much more complicated. Can I ask you a question that might sound, I don't know, I don't know how you'll take it, but I'll ask it anyway, you can tell me how you react to it. I've heard from Americans and Canadians, like people describing what it's like to go down to Los Algodonis, and people describe just walking freely through the border, like just five minutes, no need to even show a passport. And I'm just curious what that's like for you on your end, knowing that you were kicked out. And yet part of your job is to interact daily with, I don't know, hundreds of people who just walk so freely across this border, you know? The way I see it is like this. Since I am from the border, and we live in America, we went to school in America.
美国人为进入莫勒城而进行的旅程一直很简单。但当然，相反方向的旅程要复杂得多。我可以问你一个听起来可能……我不知道，我不知道你会怎么看待它，但我还是会问，你可以告诉我你对它的反应。我听美国人和加拿大人说过，比如人们形容去洛斯阿尔戈多尼斯的感受，人们形容可以自由地穿过边境，就像仅仅五分钟，甚至不需要出示护照。我很好奇，当你知道自己被驱逐出境，而你的部分工作是每天与数百个能够如此自由地穿过这个边境的人互动时，对你来说这是什么样的感受，你知道吗？我是这样看的。既然我来自边境，我们住在美国，我们在美国上学，
what happens is that when I see people come from America and I see myself that I can't go back, which is like literally right there, I can see my mom's house from right here. Oh, wow. That's the hardest thing to see. I see my house. I got the Colorado River, and I can literally see the water tank at the reservation, and then I can see all the way to the Yuma Medical Hospital on 24th Street, and then I can know more that's where my mom was.
发生的事情是，当我看到人们从美国过来，而我看到自己无法回去，而它就字面意义上在那里，我可以从这里看到我妈妈的房子。哦，哇。那是让人最难过的事情。我能看到我的房子。我有科罗拉多河，我真的能看到保护区的水塔，然后我能一直看到24街的尤马医疗医院，然后我可以确知那就是我妈妈以前呆的地方。
Vermont houses over here. If I had a drone, I could fly it over there and look at, look at it out. Yeah. That's how close I am. That's not easy. It's very hard for me. It's 5 a.m. in Algodonis. The sky is still dark, not quite sunrise.
伯蒙德的房子就在这里。如果我有一架无人机，我可以把它飞到那边去看看。是的。这就是我离它有多近。这不容易。对我来说非常艰难。阿尔戈多尼斯的清晨5点。天空仍然很黑，还不到日出的时候。
And Alberto is shuffling around the house, getting ready for work. The streets are mostly quiet at this hour. Just the sound of other promoters and ventures. setting up, setting the stage for Moeller City. By 6 a.m., he's at his post. The border opens and the Americans descend. They walk in the shadow of the 30-foot wall that divides them, crossing the very threshold, Alberto cannot.
阿尔韦托在屋里四处走动，准备去上班。这个时候街道大多很安静。只有其他推销员和商家设置摊位的声音，为莫勒城搭建舞台。到了早上6点，他已经在岗位上了。边境开放，美国人蜂拥而至。他们走在分割他们的30英尺高墙的阴影下，跨越了阿尔韦托无法踏足的门槛。
99% Invisible was reported and produced by Lashemadon and edited by Emmett Fitzgerald and Delaney Hall. Mixed by Martine Gonzalez, music by Swan Real. Voiceover and Translation Support by Ler. Laura Ubate. Fact-checking by Graham Hesha. Special thanks this week to Gabby Martinez and Griselle Costaneda. Kathy 2 is our executive producer.
《99%无形》由拉谢马·多恩（Lashemadon）报道和制作，由埃姆特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）和德兰妮·霍尔（Delaney Hall）编辑。马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martine Gonzalez）混音，音乐由斯万·里尔（Swan Real）创作。配音和翻译支持由勒尔·劳拉·乌巴特（Ler. Laura Ubate）提供。格雷厄姆·赫沙（Graham Hesha）负责事实核查。本周特别感谢加比·马丁内斯（Gabby Martinez）和格丽塞尔·科斯塔内达（Griselle Costaneda）。凯西2世（Kathy 2）是我们的执行制片人。
Kurt Colstead is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Chris Barubei, Jason DeLeon, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Lay, Joe Rosenberg, Kelly Prime, Jacob Medina Gleason, Talent and Rain Stradley, and Me Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Series XM podcast family, now at headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building.
库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Colstead）是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝伊（Chris Barubei）、杰森·德莱昂（Jason DeLeon）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、维维安·莱（Vivian Lay）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、凯利·普莱姆（Kelly Prime）、雅各布·梅迪纳·格利森（Jacob Medina Gleason）、泰伦和雷恩·斯特拉德利（Rain Stradley），以及我——罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。《99%无形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作。我们是SiriusXM播客大家庭的一员，现在总部设在潘多拉大楼以北六个街区处。
In beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our new Discord server. There's a link to that, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
位于加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心。您可以在所有常规社交媒体网站以及我们的新Discord服务器上找到我们。那里有一个链接，以及99PI过去每一集的链接，网址是99PI.org。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。